I am an angel  [Music]  you are a demon  we're hereditary enemies  get thee behind me foul fiend after you  Armageddon stays away and we've lost the  Antichrist we have to work together we  have nothing whatsoever in common I  don't even like you you do we don't find  him the water and everything where we  going  the end of the world it's not far the  earth isn't going to just end itself but  4 Horsemen of the Apocalypse are being  summoned war pollution  yes  who exactly summons them not my  department  the end of the world starts here  the boy is coming into his power you're  sure will I lie to you you're a demon  that's what you do  we're doomed welcome to the end times  it's nice Maggie we can't give up  stopped the wall  that doesn't have to be a war  of course there does otherwise how would  we win it  last great battle between heaven health  to the world  Wow  [Music]